i was evicted when i was 14 years old
and then we were forced off the island
of hawaii whether you're a celebrity or
not
whatever
and the most powerful thing you can be
is yourself you can always train and get
better and push yourself
want to soar get a mentor what's up
believe nation it's evan i believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn from one of the best
dwayne the rock johnson and some of his
best life-changing advice meant to me
dwayne also if you want to learn more
from the rock and other successful
entrepreneurs check out my 254
confidence and 254 black excellence
series where every day for the next 254
days i will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your belief and
confidence the links to join are in
description below
my call time is at seven then you back
your clock up four hours and then that's
when i get up i also believe that
anything we can accomplish anything with
our two hands getting up at four o'clock
in the morning every day before anybody
else
and grounding my thought process is in
the no one will outwork me
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be yourself
i remember i had great angst every night
before i went out because i was not able
to be myself
my very first wrestlemania the biggest
show of the year the super bowl
uh of wrestling it's not just all luck
isn't it
that night 20 000 fans started chanting
rocky sucks
it was a sobering moment
and that was the beginning of the end
of my
initial run in the wwe a few weeks later
um
i tore a tendon to my knee and i was out
for the rest of the summer and i came to
the realization before i went back that
it wasn't me
personally that they didn't like
it was that i wasn't being me
i wasn't being real i wasn't being
authentic who is this guy
in wrestling who's smiling when he's
getting beat
a few weeks later i got a call from the
wwe and i spoke to vince mcmahon he said
when you come back
we could continue to
shove you down people's throats or we
could turn your heel because they want
to boo you anyway
i said i think it's a great idea and i
said uh before we get off the phone i
run requests i said when i come back and
we go live
[Music]
i just need two minutes
live
me talking to the audience live two
minutes is all i'm asking he said okay
you got it a couple weeks later i came
back we were on live tv
i grabbed the microphone
fans were already booing they started
chanting rocky sucks
in arenas across the country i heard
chants of rocky sucks
i said um
i may be a lot of things
[Applause]
but sucks isn't one of them
but sucks isn't one of them
in that moment the rock
was born
and
about a month
later
i was the hottest heel in the company
and things were on fire
and the greatest lesson about that is
be you
be yourself
whether it's in entertainment
whether it's
out in public
whether you're celebrity or not
whatever
and the most powerful thing you can be
is yourself rule number two always give
your all i wrestled john cena and i went
in i think it's 2013 i went in wwe
champion
and uh we went and met life stadium
we
we had a record-breaking attendance
which was amazing that night
we accomplished our goal so i wrestled
with john cena we had 45 minutes planned
for the match
it's non-stop and go right so your
conditioning is tested we get to metlife
stadium it's a big night this is it it's
game night right it's it's championship
night for me
45 minute match planned out
there's no cut
there's no all right well let's pick it
back up tomorrow you know it's go time
it's just like you guys in a game
laying there
and both of us are out
i said i'll [ __ ] something's going on
and uh
i stick my hand that was 85 000 people
right and we're just laid out like this
i kind of roll over i stick my hand down
in my trunks just to see i want to make
sure that there was no bone sticking out
so there's no bone sticking out what the
[ __ ] something just happened referee
comes over and he's like rocky all right
i'm like yeah yeah yeah i think i'm all
right
i said
i get up i go to step
and i can't stop
i can't do this
i have to use my leg like momentum i
gotta do that
so now in that moment and you guys are
gonna have these moments you probably
already had them already where you're in
the game and you're in the thick of
things
and you got to make a decision
what i got to do
i'm going to stay in the game committed
to the team i committed to my team the
entire roster
right
and in the world of wrestling when you
have a big show like this and you have a
big main event that the entire show is
based around
the wrestlers will come up to the two
people in the main event at some point
all throughout the night in the locker
room and just be like hey
thank you for the house i appreciate it
thank you for the house and what that
means is that's their way of saying
thank you
for drawing helping draw 85 000 people
and putting a lot of money in my
paycheck
in my bank account thank you for the
house we got a lot of thank you for the
houses at night
bang this happens and now i realize i
can't move my leg and i got 30 minutes
left of this match
and it's not just like
around i mean these are like we got to
put on a show there's a lot of big
flying and suplexes and all that so i
could tell the rest says are you okay
and i have one moment in this moment it
was a defining moment i could either
tell him
no
i'm done
he gives the signal match is over or
let's keep going
and again this is a little takeaway for
you guys if you ever have this moment
i'm sure you have if you haven't it's
coming
we have this decision and i said no
let's keep going i said how much time is
up he's like 32 minutes
okay
wrestle the whole match
couldn't move doing everything like this
i'm getting scared because i'm thinking
man well what happens if i if i if i
pinch something or something like
you know i don't know your mind starts
with you in the moment there's 85 000
people your adrenaline rushing like man
what happens if i'm gonna lose my leg or
something like this if i've just done
something to my artery
final move of the match is his big
finishing move
and i remember
i'm getting up and i'm turning like this
because i have to fall into him he's
going to hit me with his big finishers
it's like a massive suplex where i go
over his head and slams me down and i
remember
turning i remember turning into john and
he says and i remember thinking to
myself god please don't let this be too
bad
just take care of me
take care of me
bang
it comes in the back i
get to the back i can't move now i'm
getting a little nervous
and um doctors come in
john comes in you know okay he comes in
we always like to celebrate with booze
he brings like moonshine like legit
moonshine
it's like crazy white boy that they
bring like in a jar his moonshine hey
let's have some moonshines okay
don't know what's happening rush uh
get on a jet rushed home to my doctor's
down florida
and uh get an mri find out that i have
completely torn
my adductor the top of my my adductor
and my top of my quad off my pelvis
yes really really [ __ ] up so it's a
very long story to tell you
what i was proud of was
to walk out on my own but not only that
but in this moment
where the odds are against you people
are watching your team's depending on
you you either say i'm done
or
this
whatever the [ __ ] is going on
it's temporary and it made me up at some
point down the road
but i'm not going to let this
opportunity go by without giving it my
all rule number three overcome adversity
i was evicted when i was 14 years old
and then we were forced off the island
of hawaii to move of all places we had
to move to nashville and we lived in a
little motel and i was trying to remain
as positive as i could and now your
company is called seven bucks why is
that seven bucks so my goal was to play
in the nfl and that didn't happen for me
uh i went up to the canadian football
league i played up there
i got cut from there flew back down to
miami my old man was living in tampa
i said i called him at midnight when i
landed i said you got to come get me on
the way back up to tampa i said god damn
you know let me see how much money i got
i pulled out my wallet i opened it up i
took out a five a one and change
and that's why we have seven bucks seven
bucks production rule number four always
be preparing i was raised in a household
where my old man was kicking [ __ ] out of
me at an early age um teach me hard work
and discipline i was up before the sun
with him and um
in in wrestling
uh
a world that i grew up in professional
wrestling especially in in the 80s 70s
80s where
wrestling was a lot different than it is
today um
it was uh there was no off season
obviously there's no off season in
wrestling and there's no off season then
and there's the last season now
so i think having that mentality of no
off-season and being in a constant state
of training and trying to get better and
by the way it's like look i've got a lot
of professional athletes who are my
friends ufc fighters to pro football
players pro soccer players amateur
weekend warriors um
the greatest part i think about training
is i always tell this to people is look
you can't play football forever i played
for 10 years
you can't be in the ring forever you
can't be in the octagon forever you
can't be in a boxing ring forever uh or
a football field but you can always
train and get better and push yourself
work begins work and i always enjoy
working uh and i love what i do in terms
of making movies so i'm always preparing
for some sort of role that keeps me
leading me and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus rule is
swing away i knew i wanted to be
something and it was important to me to
be something it was it was important to
me that i didn't fail but by the way and
if i did fail at least
what was also important was a lesson uh
and i didn't realize that until i got
older because you know when you're in it
you're in the grind you don't really
recognize those things uh when you're
younger but i could recognize them now
and the importance of them now and just
in terms of the drive and the
determination
a lot of it was experience too
get your ass kicked get back up and you
put the gloves back on and you swing
away
now i've got a bonus the rock clip on
how to work passionately on your craft
that i think you're really going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to swing away at number two
what adversity do you need to push
through right now and number three
how can you give it all to make sure
that you overcome it
i think a lot of people look up to in
terms of a role model for achieving your
ambitions sure what is your advice for
people watching this going i want to do
that thing
i love the way that you do this how do i
go about doing it what's your golden
rule i don't know if there's a golden
rule i can tell you this that
i believe anything is possible right i
live in the world of possibility and i
also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything with our two hands
and just putting in the work with our
two hands and also you hear this often
but it's really really true you got to
find something if you love what you do
and find and be passionate about what
you do and find something that you can
be passionate like it really helps you
know it gives you that motivation when
you wake up in the morning raise your
standard
apple at the core its core value
is that
we believe that people with passion
can change the world
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance to me
[Music]
if you want more rock check out the
dwayne johnson motivation video we did
the link is right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i can
guarantee you this it's 4 45 a.m it's
still dark outside look at that the
lights just went out and i'm getting
ready to kill this am cardio you can't
even see me